- What's up, Believe Nation?
It's Evan, my one word is believe,
and I believe in people more
than they believe in themselves
and I want some of that
to rub off onto you
so you can go off and
create those amazing things
that you've got up in here,
bring them out to the world.
So, to you help you in your
journey, today we're going to look
at the seven habits of
self-made millionaires.
Habit #7 is my personal
favorite, and I'd love to know
which one you guys like the best,
and, as always, as you're watching,
if you hear something
that really resonates
with you, leave it down
in the comments below
because, when you write it down,
it's must more likely
to stick with yourself
as well as inspire other people.
Enjoy.
(jet flying)
(sonic boom)
(ethereal music)
- I should mention one
thing about reading.
It was at the library here at Columbia--
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- that I wish I'd spent probably more
time than in any other student.
I lived there, practically.
And I pulled a book out there,
happen to be "Who's Who in America"
and that told me something
about my professor,
Benjamin Graham, and then
I went to the library,
and I said I want to learn more about this
because I learned this over here.
That changed my whole life.
You know, we own Geico now (chuckles)
because of that librarian directing me
to some other book, and then
following through on that.
It's the chance--
I read about 1/5th the
pace that Bill does,
but I still spend five or
six hours a day reading.
I mean, you can learn so much.
I particularly love biography,
just to be able to live the
lives of these people that have
been so extraordinary, the
lessons, and the discouragements
they faced, just everything about 'em,
so you can't get enough of reading.
(ethereal music)
- I have to show up at work
with the right attitude
and with the positive energy.
And, I actually had a
t-shirt made that said
"positive energy is a part
of your job description."
Right?
So, the idea that I want to
show up with the right energy,
I want to show up, we're all
here, even now we're all here,
we're trying to feed our families,
we're trying to have a good time,
we're trying to--
this is an important part of our lives,
our time is all that we have.
So, to me, it's hugely important
to deliver positive energy
in a way because it's viral.
So, if I come with positive energy,
then someone else is going to
pick up on the positive energy,
and you're going to take
it home to your families.
So, for me, it's just hugely important
to approach everything and
everybody at every turn
with the most positive, loving
kindness that I can generate.
(ethereal music)
- I get up at crazy hours, whether
it's three o'clock in the morning--
By the way, when we
were talking in London,
I was getting up at three, 'cause I had
to be on set by four, I'm sorry, by seven.
So, whatever time my call
time is, and I tell this
to studios and directors,
and our producers.
So, my call time is at seven,
then you back your clock up
four hours, and then that's
when I get up and train twice.
I'll get my cardio in and breakfast
and then I'll go hit the weights.
Clangin' and bangin', we call
it, jackin' iron. (chuckles)
- But, what time do you go to bed,
I mean you might shoot
really late at night.
- On a movie I'll average probably
about five hours of sleep.
(ethereal music)
(audience laughter)
- Do you remember the audition
when you first met De Niro?
- That was one of those
incredible auditions
that came around that, I suppose,
every kid had been waiting
for for a long period of time.
Because, it's just not that often
that you get a starring
role above Robert De Niro,
and this incredible screenplay.
It was Ellen Barkin and
Michael Caton-Jones,
and it was just, everyone
was fiending for this role.
I got down, I suppose to the final five,
and it was a last day.
Toby was there and I do
remember thinking to myself,
I got to do something to stand out.
In the audition, there was Art
Linson, Michael Caton-Jones,
Art Linson was the producer, and De Niro.
And, I remember it was
a mustard jar scene.
And, he had to jam a mustard
jar in my eye repeatedly.
It was an abuse scene.
The script didn't call
for it, but I got up.
He said, "Now is it empty, is it empty?"
And I got up and I screamed no!
Completely unnecessary,
but I screamed in his face.
(audience laughs)
And I sat there (chuckles), you know,
with my head lookin' like a red tomato
and everyone started laughing
at me in the entire room.
De Niro, everybody was in hysterics
and I sat there frozen thinking
oh, my God, I just screwed
this entire opportunity up.
(audience laughs)
And I just sat there frozen, and then Bob,
in traditional De Niro fashion
just looked at me and went,
"It's good, it's good."
(audience laughs)
And then, we carried on doing
this scene, and I actually
had dinner with De Niro
recently, and he told me,
"I was the one who said
you should get the job."
(ethereal music)
- Where did you get that business-sense
because you surpassed everybody in boxin',
in sports, in everything,
and I'm watching you like
you bigger than the NFL franchise.
- It's just my team, me believin'.
- [Snoop] Right, right.
- I'm going to be honest,
me and a lot of my guys
say I have a team also, but
my team going to get in there
and go to war like I go
to war, but they go to war
on the outside, my team go to war.
I'm very, very tough on my team.
I want my team to the
best that they can be
on the outside, but as
far as on the outside,
Al Hayman--
- That's the O-G right, there.
- That's the O-G and legend, a legend.
A very shrewd business
man, learn the L & B,
Master's Degree in business.
So, when you surround people like this,
just bein' around certain individuals,
even bein' around Don King,
bein' around Bob Arum,
bein' around just different people
that's been in the game a long time.
And my bein' their buddies.
Every time I got a (mumbles),
my bein' their buddies,
I was more like, it's cool
to come over your house,
but I need a house like this.
- [Snoop] Yeah.
- It's cool to ride on your yacht,
but I need yacht like this.
- [Snoop] Yeah.
- It's cool to ride in your jet,
but I want to jet like this.
- [Snoop] Righteous.
- And I said, no, I don't
want to ride on yours,
you show me how to get it.
You can't be my friend if you
can't show me how to get it,
'cause once they showed me how to get it,
then I can install it in my
children, then it goes down.
- It's a bloodline thing.
- Yes, so it's about wealth.
- [Snoop] Right.
- I'm not longer rich, I'm wealthy.
(ethereal music)
- We've had this tradition for
probably seven or eight years
at the company where every
week, we have a Q and A
where employees can come
and ask me any question
that they want about what's
going on and what the direction
of the company is or questions
or things that they read
about in the press, or that their friends
who use the product,
what they're asking them.
It's been this really
important tradition for us.
Both, because we really believe
in openness and communication,
and that's what Facebook
is all about, but it's also
really important for me
and for running the company
to be able to get feedback.
And, to be able to learn
what's on people's minds.
What our employees and folks who are part
of our team are thinking about.
And, a lot of the time
there are good questions
that people ask that change
the way that we think about
what we're building and what
we're here to do in the world.
And, that often make us
go think and reevaluate
how we should be approaching
different problems.
(ethereal music)
- It's hard changing your life.
It was hard when just
over three years ago,
in the Penobscot Building
in Detroit, Michigan,
where I was operating my
business, and I fell on
some hard times and I was
sleeping in my office.
It was hard coming into the
lobby and the security said,
"Excuse me, Mr. Brown, can
we see you for a moment?"
And I said yes, and I
walked up to the counter
and he gave me an envelope and he said,
"Would you mind reading it here?"
And I opened the
envelope, and the envelope
was from management that said,
"This is an office
tower, it's not a hotel.
"Please do not sleep in your office."
And I said, excuse me,
sir, I just work long hours
in creating my business,
I'm an entrepreneur.
And right now things are bad for me.
But they're not going
to be this way always.
And, I just asked for the
opportunity to continue to operate
like I'm doing, I'm not
trying to make this my home.
And, it was hard coming through the lobby
and sometimes they would laugh,
"There's the guy talkin' about
"becoming successful and look at him,
"he's bathing in the bathroom
upstairs on the 21st floor.
"He sleeps on the floor.
"Him and two other dreamers
up there, look at him!"
It was hard, ladies and gentlemen,
coming to speak to people
and I was facing financial
difficulties in my own life.
I was behind on my bills and my dreams,
and I'm saying to them,
you can live your dream!
It was hard, ladies and gentleman,
it was very difficult to pick myself up
each day believing that I could do it.
There were times that I doubted myself.
I'd say God, why is this happening to me?
I'm just tryin' to take care
of my children and my mother.
I'm not tryin' to steal
or rob from anybody.
Why does this have to happen to me?
It was very hard, and here's
what I want to say to you.
For those of you that have
experienced some hardships,
don't give up on your dream.
No one could've convinced
me by holding on,
by continuing to push forward,
by continuing to run toward my dream,
that one day I would
have my own talk show.
It's a long shot, ladies and gentlemen,
from Liberty City in an
abandoned building on a floor,
never knowing my mother or father.
It's a long shot being here with you
today in this dome in Atlanta.
It's a long shot, no college training,
labeled uneducable, mentally retarded,
but I kept running toward my dream!
(audience applauds and cheers)
Don't stop!
Don't stop running toward your dream!
(jet flying)
- Thank you, guys, so much for watching.
I hope you enjoyed, I'd love to know
what did you think of this video?
Rule #7 was my favorite,
but which one was yours?
Leave it down in the comments.
Also, did we miss an eight, nine, and ten
that you want to add to the list?
Let me know, leave it
down in the comments.
Thank you, guys, again for watching.
I believe in you, I hope you continue
to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is.
Much love, I'll see you soon.
(jet flying)
(sonic boom)